how's it going read my name s beautiful
let me know that was me why did she go
through the sewers oh that's my not a
map
yes I do want it
all right several you're not playing
around
of the nice painting
I don't want to waste that I think this
is my favorite I'll stick with this
thing
I love froggy friend ah [ __ ] all right
don't even worry about it don't make me
kill you froggy fruit I'm not - oh [ __ ]
alright bring it
brah gay bro you could have left but you
just had to follow me I don't care if
you're sorry sorry it's not good enough
all right we need to check the map all
right
froggy fro stop it sick of your [ __ ]
are there more of them did I not come
from here pretty confident I came from
here
wait it's literally impossible well
that's of no no
[Music]
fine I'll go on the other side I don't
even gay I mean I care a lot
[Music]
see I'm see how much I care
oh yeah I can walk on these I thought it
was like disgusting
huh what is that no no no please don't
introduce yourself what the [ __ ] are you
Larry's mom or some [ __ ] oh no it is not
his mom
back off I didn't know you had them off
I guess everyone has one but Jesus
Christ I don't want to meet her I look
at my health look what you did Larry's
mom
all right plan plan I don't have a plan
am I kidding I never really had one okay
where we going
let's check here first we said I want to
run that is mom nice going you totally
got me oh yes yes that was totally worth
it I need you
[Music]
batiko no what are you do that now his
mom I'm impressed
she really [ __ ] sneaks up on you
frogs now even I'm not interested out
lovely lovely
nothingness you come at me rs5 [ __ ] you
[ __ ] all of you are you just ignoring me
[ __ ] good night jack night night I'll
let our effort on this all right
Henley but that there is this far night
all right
alright quite alright Wow gone
okay nice nice nice nice nice nice nice
nice nice
hi hi come on me brother Raj in your
face how does he do that stay the [ __ ]
down I need I need to go here this here
or nowhere I'll know
I don't have anything
could you smell them stupid is that
polish I know there were Davis bonds
goddamnit
alright keep going why is it so slow
alright you can go a little faster
please demon spawns man I'll never
understand him but hi that's alright
it's quite all right ah more of them why
is it so laggy right what are you doing
I'm gonna restart this that's right it's
better now that's better
all right
jean-luc England's would go I don't have
a map of this place
Gladys is lovely
as long as there are no monkeys I don't
know that's not creepy or anything
I love carousels they're the [ __ ]
best ponies just don't let there be
clowns Oh what is that a penguin shut up
penguin I wish I know where I was going
in these I guess we just gotta find
somewhere to shell
I supposed to use my triangle or
whatever oh this is legit how about it
alright parties option don't come close
pony am I gonna write it please tell me
I'm gonna write it what the hell is
going on here I could not expect this
alright what is she doing is she in a
wheelchair I do think she's in a
wheelchair that is kind of creepy oh I
don't like this she's dead
no no Cheryl the ponies deaded they're
evil I tell ya Cheryl Cheryl no Cheryl
don't do it hey quite enough of you hmm
I wonder what's most effective maybe
this little thing hello oh don't [ __ ]
let me I [ __ ] slap you hi I told you
not a [ __ ] I met hey can you stop this
time I am health don't use tactics and
this cuz I'm not very good at tactics
alright
gonna run Fred what is she doing now
oh that is creepy you did not do that
Channel
it's against the rules but although it's
betting I get sick of this I can't I
can't go on this ah no bad Cheryl bad
Cheryl alright I'm riding the pony I
ride the pony I ride the pony what is
she doing
what the [ __ ] is this uh uh I'll kill
you oh I'll do it ah miss me [ __ ]
let's suffer this will share its Frick's
the [ __ ] out of me
[Music]
so forget you'll never use that [ __ ]
thing I never understand hi channel be a
darling and alright so now it starts and
that's when we go and shoot her or is
she where the [ __ ] is she
hi Cheryl that's quite enough Cheryl bad
Cheryl ha ha miss me [ __ ] but met met
miss me [ __ ] I'm a pony I'm a pony you
can't see this but how did you it freaks
me out every time you Josh that I can
hear you Cheryl I can [ __ ] hear you
hello sherry shoe can I call you sherry
ah ok fine I'm not gonna call you Xiao
Yu Shu you had your chance have an epic
name but no alright why the [ __ ] is she
hi Cheryl are you enjoying that good
[ __ ] you ha ha miss me
let's finish her off this has gone on
quiet enough why Shay hello shut up are
you enjoying that ah no bat-channel
alright just keep going this this is
what okay I'll shout out kidding I don't
say hello ha ha ha ok I actually did it
that didn't make sense I know but don't
worry about it I'm totally doing it all
right Cheryl I didn't join that
Oh miss me hey she can't do [ __ ] she
can't do [ __ ] she can goop [ __ ] she
can't I'll shut up
quite nice by there today hey ha ha ha
there's no whether it's this darkness I
tricked her she was gonna reply to me
that's when I hit her oh shut up
nice texture can I do it
can I do it I don't know how much ammo I
have I don't like this
um pony don't [ __ ] me why is she now
no I don't like this alright it's
hunting rifle time you made me do it
Cheryl we could have had sex together
think about it not one step closer
Cheryl no don't touch me bro
don't touch me bro not gonna die I'm not
gonna die I'm not gonna die I'm not
gonna not to my watch Cheryl not on my
watch stop it stop it stop it don't
touch my ass what the [ __ ] you should go
wait [ __ ] is she going
Cheryl night night night create a bomb I
don't have any ammo is that it yeah I
don't have an animal
I've 500 left of the shotgun no health
though if she strangles me again I'm
[ __ ]
okay
ha I don't want to die now I really
really really really why are you so fast
you're not even [ __ ] moving hey don't
hey Jeff my stepdaughter
it's over why didn't the hell how could
this ever happen that's a little sad hi
guys I'm just freaked out at the moment
oh that was Emily Jesus [ __ ] I shot that
I don't even remember her name I figured
you'd show this is creepy hold it right
there
this is [ __ ] creepy I don't know who
you are what you're trying to do and
don't care just one thing let Cheryl go
that's all I ask
why does she Wow
what all the Triforce what's this
[Music]
Lync is gonna save us
hahahaha so to get your little [ __ ]
where's Cheryl give me back my daughter
oh he's not messing around now
[Applause]
where's Cheryl where is she
I sure [ __ ] hope sir that she's a
demon spawn spawn what's going on
[Music]
[Applause]
all right a little bit
[Music]
hey what are you talking about yeah I
told you I'm not gonna have sex with her
Wow the voice acting so realistic
what
[Applause]
what in the hell let's go move
[Music]
okay that is really normal
wha-wha-what
whoa hairy ass up girl Lisa what
happened
where's Alyssa and Dahlia hairless all
right I'm listening
something you said before has been
bothering me tell me all about it I just
can't get it out of my head don't worry
about it I'm listening
what is it Lisa so I went to look in the
basement oh you shouldn't have gone
there even though I was scared as it
your brave girl you're a brave girl Lisa
like you said there were these creepy
robes but nothing really unusual down
there yeah but while I was down there I
got this weird if you tell me all about
it
been there before like something
happened there but I can't avoid
remembers all right what was it I don't
know
Harry don't worry I will help you I'm so
scared I can't take this it's only a
temporary thing all right it's gonna go
over you're in shock from when you were
knocked out don't fret about it you'll
remember after a while
know what you don't understand okay I
don't I'm sorry don't kill me wait where
do you think you're going that by the
way very pixelated damn well what's that
what's that and sound from down there
it's coming from the basement
oh we need to go to the basement yes we
need to go at the debasement breast and
we will actually do it in this episode I
feel happy I don't have a map of this
place
whoa I like this perspective oh it just
opens that's nice
I'm being summoned all right what
happened in this town what could be
making things like this I don't know
everybody they have a feeling if I take
the elevator down I'll find it don't be
another boss battle because I totally
wasted all my ammo Cheryl
uh-oh no we're back here whoa no no no
no no no that is so creepy bad girl bad
little girl I got goose bumps now this
is not good
okay hey Garrett Agatha don't let oh
we're going down in the basement I guess
so I don't see why not
whoa this is different all right are we
in the school what the [ __ ] a
screwdriver and plier I'll take that
thank you
[Music]
all righty we have a screwdriver and
some shed but we can do a nice wait
there's there only one desk in this room
it has only one desk in this room can we
find something on it
go home thief drop dead
nice I steal anything you know I look I
didn't steal anything
no look I'm not all right who wants to
die you know what if she wants to die
I'll every night come here lady lapa hey
guys so easily all right next one
I like that don't make me laugh all
right I'm pretty sure I have a map of
this place actually another one of those
[ __ ] Birds huh oh they're sick key
inside I guess I can use my screwdriver
to open it No
why not oh there's some ammo here I'll
take those
wait whoa nice room what is this can we
use this stuff okay this works nice very
nice
jolly good jolly good thank you or cliff
left
we need these keys again huh should be
too difficult I think we can do this
pretty quick play locked in here o'clock
there's a square hole in the center of
the clock it's a key can't get to it
because the glass cover that's when we
use this that's when we use let's just
break the glass no fine
eyebrows I'm gonna end this episode here
all right like a bird if you enjoy I see
that men pack there's no way I'm gonna
pick it up all right love you
[Music]
you